this week we're talking about how amazon
could bring back stargate really really
easily how either a hard reboot or a
continuation could work what storylines
might we sing
what fans might love
and what fans might hate welcome to
scitrek your sci-fi tv and movie channel
[Music]
as you'll know if you're a regular
sidetracker matt did a video a couple of
days ago where he argued that you know
would a hard reboot of stargate be all
that bad
the resounding consensus of the comments
was
yes it would be awful let's not do that
so actually if you'd like to go back and
have a quick look at matt's video again
and just put in the comments shut up
matt repeatedly that would really be
great
in that video you'll also see though
that i in several different languages
say no hard reboot no hard reboot i
don't want it
now
i'm going to be honest
this is a bit of a head in the heart
type of thing because my head says
a hard reboot of stargate might not be
that bad because the stargate series by
the end of it did sort of paint
themselves into a corner a little bit
we're really advanced it makes
absolutely no sense that the stargate is
still a secret i mean we've been invaded
repeatedly there's been spaceships in
orbit lots of times and you know we came
that close to annihilation more than
once it doesn't really make any sense
that the stargate would still be a
secret here on earth brad wright has
actually basically already said the
stargate program would have to be not
secret anymore it would have to be in
the public domain and probably under you
know civilian command now so i think
that only makes sense so much had
happened over those three series but my
heart
and you know what the heart always wins
out over the head says
no
we cannot lose those three series we
cannot just brush them under the carpet
and pretend like they didn't happen
but how could amazon do it if they did
bring back the series and they did do a
continuation well first of all the fans
we want to see a conclusion to sgu we
want to see eli brought home
i'd quite like to know what's going on
with atlantis too
we left it in san francisco bay which
never really made any sense
where is it now what is it doing what
technologies and what mysteries have we
uncovered
i also love to see where the political
situation in the galaxy is you know
what's going on with lucian alliance
what's going on with the jaffa nation
these are all big questions that i'd
love to see 11 years further on
i want to see the
or bc306 because let's be honest with
sci-fi geeks we love technology we love
new spaceships and we love geeking out
on the details i really want to see how
the technology has advanced over the
decades since sgu finished but how could
amazon do it
how could they bring back the show and
have it as a continuation and it'd still
be stargate because there is a risk with
all the spaceships and everything else
that this could become more like star
trek than star game
well
first of all i'm going to say
if you want a 22 episode series like the
good old days i'm afraid you're going to
be disappointed it's not going to happen
it's going to be 10 or 12 episodes
because
that's what stream and service series
are like now it's just
fact it's that's what it's going to be
and this series will go on to the
streaming service it will go into amazon
prime it might go to 3v but let's be
honest gateway put that idea out and
suggested that that's how it would go
but i still i think that's just stupid
free v is a
like bbc two here in the uk it's their
second channel all of their good stuff
all of the stuff they spend money on
goes on amazon prime
and that's exactly where stargate not
only deserves to be but where stargate
will end up
so we'll get 10 or 12 episode series now
that's a shame in a way because we
wouldn't get that 22 episodes
development of characters and story but
there are advantages to it for one we
could get three or four series at the
time going a little bit like what star
trek have done they've got you know
picard and discovery and strange new
worlds and we've got other series
potentially in the pipeline too
there's no reason why we couldn't almost
have a new stargate episode through the
different series on
most of the year
we wouldn't have to wait very long until
the next series came along
also 10 or 12 episodes is you know a
decent length of time to do shorter
sharper punchier series so we could do
things like
um
a prequel series of the ancients i would
love to see that i don't necessarily
want to see 22 episodes of that or
several seasons of it but one or two
seasons 10 or 12 episodes that would be
pretty cool
we could also see jaffa storylines you
know i want to see stories of the jaffa
nation but again i don't want to see 22
episodes of it necessarily but a short
sharp punchy series that'd be pretty
cool i wouldn't mind actually seeing
sort of like a political thriller type
episode as well maybe early on in the
series where the governments of the
world are trying to decide how to
announce the stargate and you know um
one of my favorite episodes um from sg1
was when there was the new president and
he was being given all the facts and all
the missions briefings from the sg-1
missions i mean that was a filler
episode but it was one of the best
filler episodes
of any sci-fi show ever i wouldn't mind
seeing sort of like that sort of you
know maybe short season where they just
have like a few episodes and they're
thrashing out the arguments and they're
you know maybe showing little flashes of
missions and things and maybe stuff
that's happened over the last 10 years
that we've missed out on
you wouldn't want to see a big series of
that but a small short season a few
episodes we could see and a new class of
maybe a bc 305 or bc 306 get launched in
its early missions i would absolutely
adore that and it would be very much
star trek rather stargate in feel
sometimes but that is grand big sci-fi
isn't it and isn't that kind of what we
want to see
we're sci-fi fans we love the
extraordinary we love the crazy you know
and maybe
the limitations of keeping the stargate
secret
were becoming a problem towards the end
and it becoming
out there forever that everybody knows
maybe run by a new civilian command that
sort of thing would create new more
interesting storylines but i do like the
idea of getting to see this universe
through lots of different lenses and
from lots of different perspectives you
know doing a jaffa story that has us the
the towery on the outside looking in
sort of thing
would be a really interesting
perspective and something we haven't
actually seen in stargate particularly
we could also see things like stargate
academy now again i really really don't
want to see 22 episodes of that i think
it would be
stargate 90210 and no thank you but 12
episodes with a very specific story arc
um you know maybe some new students some
new cadets coming through and getting
into some sort of trouble um yeah that'd
be pretty cool i wouldn't mind seeing
that um
that's the real nice thing about having
a streaming service so is that we could
have lots and lots of different stories
running consecutively
all right but stargate was always about
the exploration and the adventure and
finding new technologies to help aid
earth in the battle against
whoever the enemy was at the time the
god award the replicate is the aurai
we are now technically the top dogs in
the galaxy we have the asgard core we
have all this technology from atlantis
that we now own
where do we go from there now i did a
video not long ago saying that actually
you know what the feelings could be a
really good villain in this they could
do something really clever sort of
almost like marvel esque style where the
villain isn't really a villain in that
the villain thinks it's being the good
guy you know a bit like thanos he
actually thinks he's the good guy he
thinks he's doing the right thing i'd
love to see the furling sort of come
back and do something like that there is
storyline possibilities where the
feelings see humanity advancing too
quickly and come back and try and put us
back in our place or maybe we do
something by accident that pisses off
the feelings i think they are a massive
problem with sg1 they were a big missing
piece they kind of played up to it a few
times in history one which i did quite
enjoy and we maybe got to see a few
little flashes of the feelings which i'd
love to see played out far more detail
in one of the new stargate series so in
short
yes okay stargate did paint itself into
a bit of a technological corner here we
became very very advanced by the end of
sg1 and any new series might not really
feel like stargate that we were used to
from sg1 at least because of that
my head says a hard reboot might not be
the worst idea
but the heart always wins out over the
head and no
hard reboot we don't want it don't do it
and if amazon does do it i think we
should get together and storm their
headquarters not really amazon that's
not a threat please don't see me
so guys what do you think
what do you want to see do you want to
see a hard reboot because some people do
they think it's the only way this can
work and you might not be wrong
or is a continuation the only way to go
and please don't forget go back to
matt's video and tell him to shut up
okay okay okay no hard reboots if you
are new to the channel please like
subscribe hit that bell notification and
if you enjoy the content seriously
consider becoming a fully fled psy
tracker hit the join button and don't
forget there is merchandise on the side
dashtrek.com
a lot of it is stargate based on you can
get very cool t-shirts like this please
check it out it really helps the channel
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you